are you familiar with the superhero
firestorm he shoots fire controls heat
and wears a pretty goofy costume no well
you're about to be because injustice to
has revealed the heated fighter as the
latest addition to its roster I'm Matt
this is a game spot news update and
don't forget to hit that like and
subscribe button to be the first to know
about all of injustice tues character
reveals firestorm seems like the kind of
character that would be awesome to use
and frustrating to fight against if
you're playing someone who knows what
they're doing he's got projectiles that
look like they'll do a good job at
keeping opponents at bay but he doesn't
seem like someone you wanted turtle as
thanks to a couple moves that look like
they'll work perfectly if you want to
rush down your opponent he definitely
seems like one of those characters that
I want to face a lot so I can learn how
to effectively counter him that's about
as exciting to me is seeing a character
I want to play as injustice two releases
for ps4 and xbox one on May sixteenth
developer nether recently revealed how
its handling micro transactions and it
sounds like they'll only affect the way
your characters look nether realm even
went as far to say that it won't be a
pay to win system we'll keep you up to
date as more from injustice to is
revealed but for more superhero action
right now check out our GameSpot
universe channel where we cover all of
your favorite movies TV shows and comic
books
[Music]
you